well ladies and gentlemen please meet
dina lombang
and you are the owner of a sacramento
based um bakery called kelani cakes yes
i'm honored to introduce to you ludo and
jeffrey
beautiful beautiful cakes
[Applause]
yeah what inspired you to i mean 51st
dates your love of hawaii but like how
did you actually get it started so in
2019 i was kind of going through
something in my life where i didn't know
what i wanted to do
and my daughter who's actually here
today
she worked for the airlines and
she knew that we needed a break my
husband and i were kind of you know
trying to figure out what i was going to
do i was sick mentally and physically
and she got a job at the airline so she
could send us to hawaii
and that trip really inspired what ended
up being kalani okay these are the kind
of stories that freaked me out you
needed something you got in there
you went somewhere and you turned it
into something
uh i first of all will you turn
something into something beautiful but
to turn the restaurant business for
baking it's so hard because every one of
these things are done by hand with love
i mean it's not like you store them in a
factory until you meet them and someone
goes up and picks them up and sends them
this is love and this is daily you have
to make this daily otherwise uh it's no
good what inspired with 50 first dates
so 50 first dates is our favorite movie
to watch your husband yes when we come
home from hawaii or we miss hawaii or
just to you know get out of a bad mood
or you know when we're low and after we
came back from hawaii in 2019 i was on
my way to meet him for lunch and i was
like oh my god i know what i want to do
i'm going to make this bakery i've
always wanted to have a bakery i'm going
to have it inspired by the favorite
flavors we have we taste on hawaii and
it'll be themed after 50 first dates it
just kind
[Applause]
i asked you guys what was your response
when your mom told you the idea it made
sense it was perfect
oh it just ties everything together it's
like a full circle
okay um should we can can we taste it i
know we're looking let's go
okay
yes yes juice will you tell us about
this beautiful cake that we're so
excited sure
so this is the endless summer uh like
because of hawaii i'll be having our
summer what's in it this is a lilly koi
is the purple chiffon the middle is
orange chiffon and then the bottom is
guava chiffon wow guys guys it's so good
so much ask what the frosting is because
it's
it's got some vanilla
it's very creamy and soft i used a
mascarpone and tahitian vanilla
mascarpone
that's
[Applause]
you like buttercream you know butter but
it melts and it mimics buttercream but
it has that little bit of acid that the
mascarpone has so it balances your cake
it's very well balanced it's not too
sweet good job because sometimes it can
be too sweet you like it you already
have a oh my god
nobody is good when when drew come to
the restaurant she eats a lot i love it
yeah i do it i mean cersei
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm not one of those salad chicks who
pretends that she's on a diet all the
time i'm gonna live once and i'm going
to enjoy it um well this is just
fantastic
i guess we we're lucky enough to try the
cupcakes i'll get right in there this is
the henry roth it's inspired by
yes that one's pineapple everyone's
forgetful lucy because she wanted to
find a pineapple on her dad's birthday
everything that's right and then
this one is henry roth which is inspired
by adam's character and my husband i
call him my henry roth because when we
were going through you know some at the
beginning of kalani cakes he basically
had to make me fall in love with him
every day so i wouldn't give up and so
that's my favorite
how do you make these
i make them from my home kitchen what
yeah
i'm a i have a licensed cottage without
this for a long time cooking in my
kitchen in my home kitchen i did that
when i was doing the pop-up a little bit
i know what it is it's very difficult to
cook at home do you have a goal do you
want any advice
yes i'm outgrowing my kitchen and i'm
ready for the next step but i'm afraid
of jumping too far ahead so i'm you know
i'd love to get into a food truck i'd
love to eventually get to a brick and
mortar but i i have a lot of concerns
about you know what i need to do to get
there and i want to grow organically and
not rush so i'd i'd love some advice
about first for food truck you need
money and driver license
you know have have a food truck before
you need to be very smart with the food
truck it's a small kitchen and you need
to use all the space you can to organize
yourself because it's very challenging
but it's so much fun
[Music]